three
ah
oh wow key bo most scary oo
stoli
help me i'm fulling hey welcome to
the show don't most songs they start
when they start they sound like a
scary ghost like most songs yes oh
i had the time
a birthday hello
gosh ooh happy birthday by the way
to anyone who is selling sell selling
a birthday speak to someone who does
not want i thought of what i
was gonna do that yeah i wish
like oh man i'm gonna like a
really rich person could buy three hundred
and sixty five birthdays and make people
celebrated every single year could buy their
birthday yeah like
and the other person could no longer
celebrate their birthday it was like something
you could do to poor people to
buy your bullshit from you
i love that i wish i could
do it how much money is it
worth how much you do you like
to celebrate birthdays paul and then all
ah go over to lauren for the
um i'm paul f tompkins by the
way i am scott aquaman and over
here is high and luck is i
like to i like to celebrate our
birthdays very quietly um
as a church mouse yeah i like
to celebrate with church mice okay in
a church yeah um i i have
a tradition where for the past handful
year it's been a while now so
less than five janie and i will
been a while out less than five
oh wow
thank you it will be enough
that's it that's the tune you were
doing and it's not the actual spanish
layers that will do things and so
janie and i will go out with
another couple we'll have dinner on my
birthday and we don't like tell the
restaurant even we just like you know
and that's like all the celebration i
mean okay so shut up shut up
my fiftieth birthday is coming up yeah
i'd like to say it out loud
spoke about this the other day ah
but this year very exciting scott you
can tell him how yours was twenty
years ago
i don't understand the money
i like you too old to get
it why he has his good days
at his bad days i don't yeah
joke
yours is coming up so you're gonna
do you're gonna do a big blow
i think i'm gonna have a big
party for the yeah so how am
i on september eleven wells that's right
thank you that's really good about this
yeah doing high second yes you're right
well we we all spent together but
that i remember us your um so
ready
retainer milken stick of butter so paul
how much how much would you sell
your birthday for is what i'm getting
for since you normally it's a day
of quiet reflection and would you wait
would you wait until you're fifty first
like chip i would reiterate i'd i'd
weighed like fifty first birthday to sell
it and then how much like legitimately
you could never celebrate it again and
you could never and you could never
bring it up to anyone like this
used to be my birthday and so
then people would go oh happy birthday
in fact used to be my birthday
this is the this used to be
around i'm not say that i couldn't
say this used to be my birthday
you couldn't because then people would go
oh well happy birthday or whatever you
you you in
fact the people who knew that you
had a birthday you had to maybe
kill you know kill or or at
least flashing with the neutralizer of the
from the men in black universe yeah
so are we talking men and black
rules here men in black rules in
this scenario were just saying men and
black rules okay it's awesome rules by
the way never heard back
my agents last i heard i'm still
in the mix for men in black
two wow congratulations oh wow so see
i was one of the titular men
no no no those parts have been
cast oh okay but um i am
assuming across his role
i was doing this possibility that in
some future blu ray release or whatever
they may shoot additional footage okay and
i will be in the movie they'll
just go right to their list of
everyone who is in the mix oh
no we never we never got back
to anyways
what if casting directors had to get
back to every single person who ever
auditioned for i'm sorry you did not
get it they just like they call
you personally okay so how much realistically
you could never celebrate your birthday and
and no one could ever bring it
up again the twelve million dollars realistically
really yeah okay yeah alright
wow wow wow yeah will go lower
and then you okay how much to
never celebrate we never celebrate your birthday
again or have it acknowledged haven't acknowledged
ever again hundred million a hundred million
guys are insane like i'm talking legitimate
cash offer okay if someone was really
walking between this yeah where i wanna
buy your
earthday okay and you can never talk
about it again yeah
twenty million dollars really because life go
on with that
just what i'm thinking yeah what do
you mean i one hundred gram one
hundred and three ram yes not enough
you haley with that is not enough
barely i barely enjoy celebrating them now
iran is not enough to never acknowledge
it again or have anyone say happy
birthday tax-free do we have to commit
your giving away tax my mission condition
ratings on ten percent is just because
then we're just talking to vd it
ends up being thirty now yes i
think we owe it to listeners to
tell them what food lauren brought in
to the studio this time oh yes
we are looking at it scott yeah
would you care to describe it okay
i'll describe this food and see if
you can guess it my the way
you are you looking at it yeah
okay okay yeah you do it's um
food like ah it's in the shape
of food it's um ll
long and i guess it's in the
shape of a very curved penis i
may ask you this yeah evolutionarily speaking
yeah would you say is designed intelligently
it's you know what it's almost as
if it is intelligent because it it's
almost as if it comes in its
own wrapper
her and right and it's own you
know you know how when you get
lunchables there in those little containers and
then you peel back the plastic on
top of them yeah like babies or
bleed every day
i like my lunchables i'm sorry
scott as a sodium deficiency like one
i either have to go swimming in
the salt water of the ocean what
are the worried looks like they're like
it's like a little like soft cracker
with the new rubbed on tomatoes raw
oh god can't you just spread it
ready you massage tomato sauce into it
that's what i said
oh yeah and then you eat it
it's you microwave know you could if
you were home but you're at school
what are you gonna do true true
you don't have access to the school
microwave don't let you do that they
should have a microwave one microwave one
early or the hundreds of kids
but you know kids who put metal
in there oh stupid kids hey what
kind of lunch box do they still
make lunchboxes it's a banana by the
way hey yeah has been yeah i'm
so weird um we all had rice
cakes and peanut butter yeah i did
and i also had breakfast before that
pony
and of course if you're listening please
party on a secret message coming to
you in the midst of this show
thank you do still make lunch sachs
three oz i like what kind of
lunchboxes you have when you were a
kid i had i had a wizard
of oz lunch box of the movie
or yeah the books the movie it
ran through therapy
miss judy garland and you know wizard
of oz is interesting because it's one
of the few like
oh thank god he's definitely lauren
no it's one of the few classic
movies that has a female protagonist true
you know what i mean i think
it's interesting because like a scare crow
came to light oh well like i
don't know i never noticed that lion
walked on his hind legs yeah tin
man huh
a man of tin
hey you didn't even have a heart
when you think of that movie came
out now you'd be noted to death
by the studio like it's well it's
a strangely structural and then they did
that um oh no that that wasn't
like updated i guess they did the
ways that live went on ah oh
yea oh yeah did you watch i
did i watch all those i lie
watched them all up but but about
how
half of them i stopped midway through
saying oh this is no good i
enjoy when it's bad really um i
enjoyed the first one the sound of
music that was terrible i remember like
i think we all gathered together at
like sarah silverman's house or something because
he's was the first one in a
long time and we were out we
all love musicals like come on over
and then within three minutes
i was like oh this is a
bomb yeah look like a soap opera
one sometimes they're really strange when they
don't i think most of them don't
have an audience and i find that
really weird yeah because it's like this
reminds me of like those ones you'd
watch growing up but like it's weird
like it just seems like yeah silo
fox live yeah like oh wow yeah
yeah yeah the fox greece one too
care that in a great way yeah
like a lot of it had an
audience and people cheering you know like
did hell that one was a great
one did you watch the christmas story
i watched about an hour of it
i watched it over the course of
two days it was very long but
you know who's amazing is that guy
from silicon valley who apparently is a
broadway guy which dude from silicon valley
eau de crow what's his name you
should go with lambert
yeah yeah korea chris i don't know
his name i looked it up on
the trot but he is swashbuckler ah
why am i looking up yeah because
i just couldn't forget a broadway back-row
broadway background he was amazing yeah um
he was all he made it worth
it but never do musicals learn not
really no i
couldn't get into any of them why
did you audition audition for ever they
call you back um maybe once in
a while were you ever in the
mix know
um no what did you audition with
a song from the show or some
other show is usually a song from
the show um i don't know i
couldn't get into any play or musical
at my school really interesting yeah i
wonder why that is right where you
are you an introvert um no but
i you know i thought
think part of it my school had
just like a lot of like really
good actors and people who are really
like obsessed with musical theatre and stuff
but they were just great but i
always do we talk about this before
because i really want to watch like
videos with high school plays and see
if they were actually yeah we talked
about this a little bit about yeah
they're they're all we imagine them as
these great productions but they are
probably all were terrible i know um
the way we are transmitting before this
ah okay let's bash through time just
talking about those musicals i love sitting
down and watching like a live event
and i love award shows for that
same reason and yet i invited you
to a football game yesterday comes it's
first of all sorry
second of all not only that but
did not even ever give me a
real answer as to whether you were
coming but i assumed you understood that
we didn't watch by the time it
was over i was like yeah i'm
pretty sure they're not i'm sorry i
wouldn't i would have been more clear
i thought oh no i yeah i'm
doing bits with you but yeah um
i think it would be like just
a horrible guest because i don't kid
was mainly i
i would have been too that's why
no i knew you were out of
town
it was mainly just because i wanted
to cook this brisket oh well damn
and i did well thanks for inviting
us it was a shit job
we had a nose like a lot
of people and you wouldn't need my
like i don't know it was like
missionary it was thirteen okay or whatever
it was and we had the exact
lucky i think i know yes it
was very unlucky we all ah broke
our arms
watching the football yep
was wearing to re-enact yeah we're pretending
we the quarterbacks right sure we were
moving our arms back and forth and
you're also old and forward passing yeah
motion work paths um you you have
never you said you have never watched
a football game no that's not true
i mean i grew up my dad
and brady grow up watched that stuff
ask so i've seen a lot
out of that tie it's just white
noise to me i hate it i
yeah sound of football yeah i really
so you are not ready for some
football i'm never ready for some football
do you think you're just don't like
i've told my random stranger to stay
at home what's the one sport you
would you like baseball i like baseball
do you love football i go in
in and out of the various years
where i have never watched a single
game except for the super bowl and
then i'll watch a lot of them
especially if i'm if i'm betting on
them then i'm will see this is
fun stephanie allen was just telling me
about how she bet on the bills
and they are known to lose all
the time but they were doing whatever
she bet on them and she would
have stood to win thirty thousand doll
oilers if they won the super bowl
well
hey just passing hundred dollars oh yeah
the odds are so stacked against right
right um but i was like i
got a gamble i gotta get on
this and that makes sport seem fun
to me it's ironic that she bet
on the bills and she would have
won so many bills yeah isn't it
yeah run it's like oh i do
not like to gamba
lol are you a gambler i really
enjoy like roulette if i'm in vegas
i have a great time i'm terrible
play for but i'll play for hours
because i kind of make it last
like i don't spend a lotta money
but i can see the odds the
terrible odds making it kind of exciting
because that one good shot right yeah
the right number oh my god yes
i'm screaming i love it yeah but
but i it is horrible like you
typically will never win like anytime i've
come i've i've had moments where i'm
like way above what i came in
with but that rose at all but
it's i just chalk it up to
like i got to play a game
for four hours right yeah fun i
got to yeah when i did one
hundred bucks i don't put right yeah
a few tons of gambles
like when i am losing the money
it feels so bad and it makes
me so anxious like what am i
right what am i doing well it
is crazy when you play a game
like roulette because i go in there
going like i'm i don't care if
i lose one hundred dollars i'll play
this as long as i can and
then there'll be people who are just
just throwing down so much money and
losing
it's so fast and it makes me
feel insane like watching them yeah i'm
like what is wrong with you like
that's crazy because it's the worst game
if you actually want to win like
a shit ton of money yeah this
guy was saying so this guy he
was just putting down one hundred bucks
like every time and it was just
like he was spending thousands and thousands
of dollars time and then he kept
like you get like
i have a flight to catch a
show my wife's like my way should
be mad at me i gotta get
out outta here and then like just
kept going and then he'd walk away
and they go oh and come back
and put on like a serious gambling
problem it was really upsetting a gambling
problem a gambling addiction seems so horrifying
to me like even more than a
drug addiction for some reason i don't
know if it's
just the i guess it's just the
i guess with the anxiety because the
drug addiction you know what you're getting
well it's just not it's not like
you're gonna i mean yeah it's also
it's a physical thing yeah it's like
you are ah you at least know
you will get the respite of the
drug i guess if you can get
the well i know people who are
x
ks drug addicts alcoholics who are now
gambling at it yeah i know because
it's just another way to yeah which
i get in some ways saver but
in other ways you're losing all your
money and it's not just the anxiety
of it i know it makes me
feel crazy yeah don't feel put down
like ten grand i'm like you're out
of your mind i don't know what
ah ah i'm a guy
ambler no i don't i don't ah
it shouldn't actually when i was when
i was twenty making me want to
gamble
because now when i was twenty four
i guess or twenty three or twenty
four i would go to vegas a
lot and then ah because i didn't
have any money i had just come
back from milwaukee make sense good yeah
just get a job i just come
back from milwaukee where i basically spent
all my money trying to
to fly back to los angeles and
i had to move it back in
with my milwaukee what were you doing
wait oh what was the maki school
no like good good so i moved
to milwaukee on halloween to be with
my girlfriend and then on november first
november shares a witch
on november first he said i'm not
in love with you anymore
italy yeah yeah let's suck and yeah
and so then by christmas last halloween
i moved to milwaukee nevada foe
i was in the airport on christmas
eve with like my all my possessions
in a trunk and i was a
big holiday and i was out of
money and they weighed the trunk and
they were like this is overweight it's
going to be seventy five dollars probably
all the stickers right the sticker show
me your steamer trunk yeah there were
there weirdly
i told you about this trunk oh
weird i know you pretty well
i we were talking about the trunk
the other day i got it out
of adding just the other day i
was walking down the street where i
told you i i got this trunk
from a from a roommates room old
room mate he had left it in
the apartment and it had stickers all
over it and when they when we
oh we use like do you want
this truck
oh my my roommate left here when
we opened it up it was filled
with books about charles manson says yes
or oh my god the guy was
a strange yeah and so i had
like a cursed trunk for a while
and so i went to the airport
within their like this is a world
filled with yes like every bottle come
available i don't know and it had
right you know his own writings and
and stuff ooh so anyway i would
carry everything around with it and they
said this is overweight you need to
pay seventy five dollars and i i
just i went white and i said
i don't have any money and they
said merry christmas and they like packed
it up and they send it back
anyway so i didn't have any money
so
ooh and it was love the manson
books yeah that's all i carried with
me like these are good why did
i say yes drunk now just just
your troy when you went white did
you ever go back
um so let's say oh yeah so
i so i go to vegas with
a friend and i was working at
the olive garden but ah were there
to pass your family that's nice um
dann sprays which by the way i
was telling this to our friend tell
john the other day
like how many proposals there were when
i worked at all of garden is
that depressing oh yeah weak isn't it
makes me sad so i would i
would make if someone proposed to me
there
i do have to say yes ah
when anyone yeah yeah
so i would make like i would
i would have like four hundred dollars
is something we would go to vegas
and then that's when i got into
like blackjack and the mechanics of it
and so i spent a i spent
a good couple years where i would
go to vegas just to make money
and i would work yeah and i
would come back with like a couple
of thousand dollar
there's something yeah i remember like the
biggest bet i ever made was fifteen
hundred dollars on a single hand and
then i then i just oh man
i just did you win yeah i
would win yeah basically like got got
got a car and moved out of
my parents' house like i started like
not how it's supposed to go yeah
not at all but it was just
the art of like grime
is what i was into of just
like betting zazu yeah anyway so but
but then i just gave it up
and i just haven't done it in
fact i went with the writers of
bang bang to vegas maybe two years
ago and they none of them knew
how to gamble none of them had
ever ever played like blackjack they're all
like such dorks just like never
they're all like how do you do
this and i was like oh here
come sit down at the blackjack table
i'll teach you how and they're like
i'm really cool hold on just like
they're all in their thirties and they
never i i've gambled with alford and
louie were really see case louisiana
i don't know if it was zoe's
gamble with whom we just did roulette
and and hanford just kept losing this
so so he just bet it all
on double zero eight as for more
tips loser mall god made me laugh
so i showed them all how to
play blackjack and it was like the
first time i'd played in a decade
or something i was like oh here's
how you do it and then within
ten minutes i was like six hundred
dollars up and they're like wow so
this is how you play i was
like ah the other the other part
of his like know when to walk
away from the tables i was like
yeah alright i'm stopping now
now like my problem is because i'm
like i can get ahead and then
i'm like well now i have a
lot to play with running lose it
yeah yeah um anyway that's the the
story of my gambling you ever bet
on sports oh when i said i'd
tell you when i said i gamble
on sports it's i'm only i'm in
of i'm in a football pool every
year with a like a brand build
with
football's you see i just can't do
it the gamble is will i get
out before i smothered today
because you're having so much fun i
had a dream last night i drowned
and woke me up oh he gasped
for air as you're waking up i
knew it was a movie here's the
thing well it's not a movie i
knew i knew i was an actor
in a movie and that there were
people all around me and then i
started thinking about the safety precautions of
the movie of like of like oh
i wonder how they're doing this to
where if i drown and then i
was like oh wait there are none
then i wonder how they shoot things
like that and movies do they'd use
like a big tank like like one
like like the abyss are so yeah
they would have a big tank so
weird titanic that's so weird they were
just sitting in a big tank and
the big
aqua man remember aquaman yeah
dr roz yes ah look we have
to take a break alright fine alright
we'll see next time she died i
mean next segment by what could be
the next see
we're back hello hello we're seeing you
know hi we're here hi please come
in please come in andrea ooh
how come there hasn't been like a
funk song entre vous
not a person that's the question i've
been asking for years it doesn't seem
perfect i want to trim their own
true blue to a go poo while
there was oulu there was really vu
and you think this would be the
natural follow-up and there was a reliever
who label cache of eyeglasses a marma
ah voulez vous was laid ah abu
then there was lady marmalade i hate
that new version hits me huh what
newer they announced the people from fifteen
years ago the wow yeah christina that's
like bothered me pink
maya i hated it i kinda like
dough
huh it's so annoying it's good oh
it's good now it's now it's good
now i'm sorry
what is your guilty pleasure song that
you love that people hate i like
some country songs that i think people
you had me that i liked some
cunt
she kept listening
no i'm just talking whiskey ah my
genius guys look like you're like coffee
i eat so little in there okay
let me just get one more goal
um i'm parsing out my squid don't
i wanna be able free to talk
getting a lot of cheese meal um
i like this one song play i've
got a bbq cinema watch t shirt
yeah i can't cry at country songs
like really easily like really if a
song came out like i was watching
a new year's eve performance
nsw by ten lady isabel na oh
my
um lady antebellum just the media
yeah and it was really cheesy and
i was like this is so good
like i just sometimes the songs are
so emotion there's a lady antebellum song
the cool up and i sing all
the time really yeah i can't remember
what it is it's the one where
what is it i can't remember well
i like this one song called seventeen
by eric church can you play it
it's about the age
that he likes to date yeah
um yeah nick wire and tweet about
how like rough i can't remember what
the actual tweet is but roughly a
third of rock songs are all about
how a woman is under age but
i still want to date there are
so many ways yet there are so
many there are a lot yeah they
pop up all the time just done
someone was posting about how jerry seinfeld
who is third
the nine dated seventeen shushannah whatever took
jenna lowenstein yeah yeah very weird fucking
crazies and sunny apparently he has a
kid who's seventeen now and people i
remember and i'm the tie on my
site sell him or her
at the time it was like people
made jokes about it and maybe there
were a few people saying later propria
yes she was in high school yeah
yeah yeah yeah he had a tv
shows damn i'm guessing that was on
that that's a big fan love to
have a yoma show seventeen by whom
eric church church eric church it's just
really good
church we want to hear the song
that i sang i mean length thinking
do you have a guilty pleasure saying
while this is getting there's one speaking
country i was watching either happy it's
being of good thank you
either i was watching either extreme home
makeover or the sixty minutes
remember which but morley safer was building
yeah so hard to tell
ah maybe it would have been better
of his jimmy carter
no really they were building i know
but like a lot technically anyway
just fine i like it that's great
yeah three wishes was the one that
kula worked on as a logger ah
the amy grant hosted one where they
bill eat houses i didn't follow any
longer ah okay there's a show called
languishes where they would build houses and
any grant was the host of it
okay and cool off would law
ugh the tapes meaning she would type
everything they say okay that's a job
that a lot of like people at
usb and stuff they they they they
have when they move out here is
just reality show logging so cool i
was not cutting down trees to build
these houses for amy grant no but
she she worked on bringing steam that
seventeen she springs that's me season
gasoline in the song okay um so
so she worked on that and then
she became a producer on america's got
talent weirdly enough from that so she
produced america's queen hello please blogger i
just explained it i was ah i
was listening because we were dealing with
the song cheat sheet you watched the
tape and you type it but every
things that happening it's about a house
she was a lawyer yes we went
through we went through all so you
had that conversation and then did you
say because i thought yeah oh yeah
we did all we did all actually
covered everything all of it not but
actually this okay i'm never free
ooh
stay to the south
i love this back and still hear
the sound of you saying did you
play this in a way
there was a song you played a
watch now
but i'm thinking without
like a rock stars in the sky
this
that country thing of i'm gonna make
a list of things i'm gonna say
this list of this is my lifestyle
it fucking works every time i love
it like it's very success playing a
lot it was somebody who's gone woman
oh so
oh anyway so cool up yes she
was a producer on america's got talent
where basically she would convince people who
were terrible that they were that the
judges probably thought they were good and
to get them to go out on
stage and say oh my god i
started hating it so much and your
asshole hoff was there at the time
anyway these other feels so bad as
are her story yeah these are her
stories it was like when i worked
when i worked at the la times
and i was like salesman of the
month what for a while
convincing people to buy the paper and
it became so easy for me where
like i could get anyone to buy
it and i started feeling so bad
that i quit what do you guys
pointing at yes
these are her stories that i did
the load order sell
and is that part of law and
order yeah these are their stories oh
i didn't know they played the the
two branches of right order no nobody
heard except say i heard it i
didn't understand
anyway
on one of these shows
yeah there's still this on one of
these shows brad brad paisley was on
it yeah and he sang a song
about how he was adopted ah he
i can you look this up sam
he didn't have to i think is
what it's called brad paisley and he
it's a song oh gosh i'm like
magically oh wow
tight it's about it's about his dad
not having to love him but he
did all my dies due to be
with someone adopting him no no sir
his dad his dad that's so good
do we have it's say same idea
find out about me
row row e
honestly about to drive man i coma
dad when i was five years old
took my mom out to movie and
shot her in the head
hello daddy
if you
over heard him up was obviously can't
deal with motion huh
and then all of sudden no it
seems so strange to see scott all
of us i know
i'm trying to train myself i'm glad
brad paisley is backing me up
looking back all i can say about
things he did for me
a anyway
wait dazed and
he didn't have to be wow yeah
i like that's a i seriously just
talking about ai anyway so that's great
so i remember now i'm hopped up
like finding that in my i-tunes or
somehow i'm like what is this and
then me
not even being able to explain it
without tearing yeah by janie and i
once were going we were ah taking
a trip to palm springs we're driving
down we made this playlist for the
road and i just gotten this ah
avett brothers album and hadn't listened to
it yet and so this saw
i think i'd seen them the the
thing that made me get the albums
i'd seen them do this song on
a ton of appetite was doing a
documentary about him did he yeah so
i gotta get my knowledge
cause i ever want to see jeddah
i want to see it too and
already our documentary everything so the song
call is called ah this is called
murdered in the city and it's murdered
in the city yeah wow if i
get murdered in the city don't go
avenger my name so sam could we
played out here a little bit of
the avid brothers murdered in the city
things that i think of
no need to get over along
i'm coming home
recap rector elba guitar solos
funding what my dad would say
you said i love you and i'm
proud of you both in so many
different ways
it's a really pretty song and
i've never this has never happened before
but i started crying and then janie
was crying too like we checked in
with each other like are you are
you crying who was like yeah i'm
crush who's driving janie was driving okay
you think i can't cry drive to
won't
ah but it was it was a
crazy experience because it it caught us
by surprise because we just happen to
be present in the moment yeah let's
do it at the same time yeah
and then like as it was going
on like when you start to feel
like your your your nose starts to
tingle you don't feel like you feel
in your face it's gonna start happening
it's like and then
you go through that thing of am
i going to start crying at the
song i always i cry at songs
a lot like my car for two
seconds like it'll just be like but
i always think it's funny to if
someone could watch that because it's just
like driving along like
then it's gone you're like okay
like what does this woman is a
lunatic for two seconds over you just
squeeze out like two tears pulling the
windshield huh
what do you think
just slowly installed for that purpose
okay look we have to take another
one sorry
welcome back welcome back welcome back due
to do wow welcome back welcome back
welcome back how do you know that
song from welcome back kotter used to
watch welcome back kotter
mr da
i loved that show when i was
a kid i love it i never
watched it it's terrible i've seen yeah
bad but i um you are makes
me think of head of the class
which i definitely watched a lot more
trista i don't remember saying well was
i babysat for it's one of the
actors like what i moved here one
of the act
waters kid which one howard hessman billy
conn valley okay hello yeah damn valleys
yes absolutely um and i remember being
like that's so cool like you know
when you move here then suddenly there's
like someone who you watched on tv
tell us all their dirty secrets yeah
oh nice winter so when you suggested
our house yeah i guess i'm
weird shit
she was so great she was so
do you if you're staying in someone's
house do you like look in their
stuff oh no the todd
i don't because i always really like
fear that somehow they'll know i did
that right but i do slyly open
medicine cabinets i feel like you know
in a bathroom if i hear it
i don't always think of it though
yeah i don't but i feel like
people talk about it like it's an
extremely common thing like you know every
one does this well i always fear
that i want to help someone take
care of my pets don't go through
my shit because i wouldn't do that
if i were like taking care of
my actual yes if it was someone
i didn't really know that might be
more chance that i would do that
well i never want to do an
air bnb with my house right yeah
jamie's talked about it like if we're
going away we
could make money by doing that i'm
like i don't want that and she
says well you know you you can
hide all your stuff undermining the murder
dungeon it's not
it's not even about them snooping is
just about people just about there is
this mills yeah just about their like
their molecules yeah don't want their molecules
in there it is weird it's i
don't it feels like if we were
ever to have a like a beach
house or something i would just want
it to be shuttered when we're not
there like yeah
anybody in shuddered on the beach i
want to shut it on the beach
thinking maybe some shutters on the beach
i used to babysit all the time
and my first snoop so i feel
like i have maybe i don't have
that instinct you don't do help yourself
to whatever's in the fridge well yeah
but when they say help yourself to
whatever's in the fridge yeah they always
did right yeah i wouldn't just do
something they didn't say but always cleaned
i always went like above and beyond
but i went and so now when
i know that like people i know
who have babysitters and they don't do
the show my fucking do the dishes
it's part of the job doing the
nets very way of doing the dishes
that you used or just doing whatever
dishes happen to be bad and there's
a sink of dishes that should be
done by the time the inner tourist
eating i like doing stuff like that
if i stay at somebody's house yeah
like to sure to delete it a
little better than i found it yeah
when we we ran into a house
up in santa ynez ah a few
years back and for for a week
and cool up like those above and
beyond and she like clean like coola
she claimed that place prison
she cleaned it so well that we
forgot our blender like a big expensive
blender when
and we drain you left it there
we left it there and we drove
back and two and half hours later
and we were like god what do
we do do we just drive all
the way back for two and a
half hours and then drive another two
and half hours and she called them
and they they had come into the
house and they were like this place
looks so nice we will pay to
have this show oh that's nice
well you should have any way to
ya fuckin assholes we just hate you
a decent human beings right it's time
to play a feature what do we
got lauren what do you got did
you bring something whoa yeah
this game is called celebrity hunt okay
finally the most dangerous games now the
so basically during lloyd brixton will say
isn't it easy bill lloyd bridges had
a show called ceyhan yeah if you
just like and they got away with
it yeah boy because we all know
what he was hunting yeah okay the
one person will see a celebrities name
name then we'll all say hunt right
then the next person says a celebrities
name that starts with the last letter
of the previous celebrity's name okay and
how did and then we all say
hunt until someone tells someone just so
what i try to keep giving go
faster and faster also we could add
a wrinkle where you have to say
living people and if you say oh
if you say dead
per se and then i also think
no one say dolores o'riordan if it's
from the cranberries the die just happened
today i didn't know that yes that's
horrible it's the lead singer yes oh
my god she's amazing we were talking
about the cranberries on stage this weekend
really she just they were just touring
yeah how did you die let's hope
she doesn't turn into a zombie
nah me
this joke has already been made a
million times by the time it comes
out five months later um wait why
did how did you pass away i'll
look i don't know we don't know
if i'm wrong no one knows let's
just try let's try the regular version
yes and and well i think it
goes down when you try to go
a little faster and then if someone
can't think of one in a reasonable
amount of time they're out
okay got it okay so
i was gonna start you ready and
we all have to say hunt and
paul is looking at his phone i
was trying to see what dolores o'riordan
died i don't think there's this
a i pick up oh my
ricky martin hans
natalie imbruglia hons
ashton kutcher harsh
ridley scott hodge tom eggs huh and
as steve martin hunt natalie portman hunt
de de de de de de de
did the doctor leone funds
echo kellum yeah huh and he's on
a show okay this absolutely throughout the
show um um michael douglas hunt ah
sam smith hunt horatio sanz hot oh
oof
oh
it's a social mamet huh yeah true
yes z yeah i'm thinking i'm an
next okay ah that ah i bet
you did did did did did did
did did did
um um terry crews hans sam smith
you already said that i sam smith
you said i said yeah oh sorry
i mean go out ok i guess
so what's it sam smith yeah yeah
hey i'm so sorry one
will said sam sparrow oh well there's
three of us okay well also what
was the last one before sams oh
so that terry crews terry kercher um
um sam rockwell hans ah lolita davidovich
hynes um hunter s thompson hi he's
dead oh shit
yeah i thought we were doing the
regular okay oh whatever yes we were
any people we said dead before i
don't think no i don't think so
ratio of ratios as of this recording
oh god i'm ok that was okay
i like weed so much pausing mostly
for me should we do it again
and have a more specific category oh
like spas of lainey it has to
be like the soviet just yeah we're
like yeah or like ok something like
that you wanna do movies like they
have to be movie actors or movie
titles
i guess we can do movie title
let's try with movie titles okay yeah
yeah alright alright go yeah um the
little mermaid
for commonweal
ah death in venice huh and can
i ask just quickly oh boy does
the account no no ok okay would
you say death notice okay hunt um
it
hi
e e
and you're the dragon
fuck you into the dryer that's fine
you gotta give me one um um
um
ah nice
that's stupid
well if you get a certain word
gang down and set the adventures of
natty yeah i wanna get
wait i'm not out yeah keep going
all right ah so i said to
enter the dragon alright um um natural
born killers hunt
um
someone to watch over me huh but
ah eternal sunshine of the spotless mind
funds um
day of the dead huh it's dawn
of the dead huh
um davey earth stood still coming
lolita hunt after hours haas ah shits
the standard deliver aha and in return
of the killer tomatoes hot wow um
ah a scandal huns ah last
of the mohicans hunt ah stargate tons
ah
a a a movie guy
ah yeah
a movie the seinfeld next one
the movie eg movie man
why is that have anything to do
with beam because
susan down to use a movie about
it so he just would do anything
any noun well he counties my point
across would be movie i get the
play on words and movie now that
that's out of the way and this
is not open this up there is
it about anthropomorphic egg yeah for sure
yeah
fucking find it's nest yeah they think
they can find it's best what was
the movie about what was the plot
of one saw that was it about
an actor b movie i was working
in dreamers have the time and i
i remember they had a read through
of it and they were like oh
my god this is so funny
oil boy yeah you know yeah yeah
yeah well that was that was fun
no it was called celebrity hunts i
don't know why you've just screamed behind
what have you got extra points for
if you i guess hunter s thompson
would have been extra points because it
has hunting the actual and tang dar
al
and hunt of the red october hunt
for red october hundred on for the
red october also woody allen's celebrity if
you got the head in there that's
true with kenneth bra doing the best
woody allen impression valuable i love you
you know i love that people don't
have to apologize for having been in
woody allen gives their money back yeah
i honestly kind of want to give
my money like i'm donating my salary
from a different movie that has nothing
to do with this
just get some headlines some good press
you're gonna get those i mean any
donation you make is part of your
salary that's true but it's like how
were you saying unless you find a
woody unless you found the money in
a treasure hunt huh huh and turn
to the sierra madre what if we
did this but it's treasure
orhan we had to name different types
of treasure okay alright let's go ray
ruby's hot diamonds huh hey no start
with the letter
you can just sense yeah i
like very important to it i always
in the same place where it's just
like just naming treasure things it's like
the whole thing
it again alright ruby's hot swashbuckler yeah
yeah yeah super fires high and ah
some doubloons oh stop making it all
oh
stop making it plural huh
ah stop making it plural not about
title
the fatal flaw
fatal flaw we should have a feature
called fatal flaw on ruby ruby
i'll just become so moore's old
some different gold
some different goals different finance
ah
ah a good shit alright we're out
of time yeah right we're at a
time we'll see you next time bye
bye
ugh this has been an era with
production executive produced by scott ackerman chris
bannon and colin anderson for more information
and content visit airwolf dot com